okay yanny has got his ultra blue light
glasses on and how do you how are you
feeling about them
i just feel innocent whenever you put
glasses on all the bad thoughts you've
had
all the crimes you've committed
throughout your life glasses
is just kind of what defense attorneys
recommend their clients put on
i mean it's really funny to see a guy
who's got tattoos
on his face at his neck and a pair of
glasses trying to send a message to the
jury saying hey
i'm just a normal good guy i'm just a
normal good good guy because
um yeah i feel like um i feel like the
the truth of the sich is after watching
social dilemma on netflix is that
google and everybody else all these
companies they just have
everything on us they've just watched us
jerk off to things we're not supposed to
jerk off to
they've just they have everything on us
and it's just any moment they could just
turn it on and ruin your life
so that's why people get up and start
apologizing and start saying that
they're gonna vote democrat and all that
it's just because they're liars
yeah they almost like it's like what is
trump
uh what does putin have on trump who
cares it's like what does google
have on all of us that's the real deal
that's the person behind the curtain
that's the wizard of oz it's not putin
it's
google because putin is my president i
don't know who yours is but putin is
mine
my putin putin's my president i want to
know how um
what's going on with the air quality out
there that it has
it has made your square your head back
into the mcdonald's moon man how did
yeah what is going on the i well the air
quality was really bad here the last few
days but now for the first times i could
see
blue skies in this blue [ __ ] state and um
i'm kidding i can see if there's blue
wave g and say no i'm kidding blue skies
in this blue lovely state i love the
gays love everyone i'm getting gayer and
gary by the second out here
um something's in the smoke and i love
it um but uh
yeah i i uh you know it's what it is
because
i mean i gotta be honest with you i miss
home i heard that it's chilly
in new york i don't know how it is in
new hampshire but it's [ __ ] chilly in
new york and there was a light drizzle
and i just want to go back home to where
it's [ __ ] cold
yeah two questions what i mean one yeah
your head does look like it's in a vice
grip like just someone squeezing you by
the sides
trying to get some information out of
you like
that joe pescina casino that's my first
statement the second one's a question
are you having sex with donny yes we did
and it's
just what it is because we both got
coven 19 tested and it's just
what it is yeah because you got a big
pimple on the head of your nose
are you doing well i just popped it i
just
right before the show started i just
popped this pimple i've never gotten a
pimple on the edge of my nose but i
guess it's just been rubbing my nose up
in guys butts crack since i've been out
here
sometimes it clogs your pores because
does anybody have questions
isn't it fun to just take your [ __ ]
hands off the handlebars and just
just and just battle yeah it's just fun
it's just fun i i mean because the truth
of the situation as we say this almost
every episode
but nobody really cares so anybody that
tries to give you advice or
anybody that tries to say do this do
that it's like just shut the [ __ ] up
nobody cares you're all narcissist it's
always about you i'm aware
look look what's up what's
your guy show your ass pull your ass out
a little bit yeah pull your ass out just
a little bit
there it is you see that folks yeah yeah
you got your room and died so you got a
hotel room but you're sleeping at
donnie's
i'm sleeping at donnie's yeah the show
paper hotel room i only go there i got
some bags there
and i got um i got some chocolates that
i stashed there but other than that yeah
i just don't give a [ __ ]
i'm not [ __ ] going to sleep uh i'm
not going to sleep over there
uh because you know it's just i want to
be i want to be close to
you know donnie i just want to be here
and is that because
in case you see a ghost or whatever
there's just help or why
yeah because yeah because la's a lonely
place and it's [ __ ] already like hard
enough to be out here alone so i just
want to be close to guys and
plus i like the way don's aftershave
smells
arrows from san antonio because he's a
kid from san antonio just gave us 49.99
so we know that's a big part of his
stimulus check
chris you can't do that i'm pretty sure
you can't do that
i'm pretty sure you're back we also have
a producer who's not a man
you can't do that i was tucked
back yeah i mean i'm still pretty sure
you can't do that yeah i can
okay well um richie g's here and bubba's
just prepare for this
he's big yeah richie g is coming into
the chat
like this like he's a [ __ ] nfl player
in the strip club in the middle of the
suburbs of atlanta
[ __ ] richie g's coming in with 250
dollars
no reaction wow yeah 250.
so yeah 250 bucks
yeah richie g saying i'm late bubba's
happy belated birthdays
yannis yanni here's something small to
celebrate the birth i like that's a
little something small for richie g
250. uh johnny here there's something
small to celebrate the birth of your
first child thank you richie i really
appreciate it
thank you he says i'll be an amazing dad
and then he says chris
best of luck while you're out in l.a
you'll obviously crush the pilot as well
as all other appearances it's only up
from here so chris
richie g's just coming through with the
real dad vibe here he's just giving us
well wishes richie i appreciate it
brother and listen when i get out to
kansas city
uh or if me and yanni both get out to
kansas city i mean you're
you're gonna get taken out on for a
night on the town and you're gonna get
held down and you're gonna get sexually
assaulted so it's just what it is
that's not a threat that's a promise
thank you richie g
yeah it's one of the late and by the
tone of your message obviously you're
very very sober
and that you're late obviously you did a
lot of [ __ ] white
lady last night now that this is not
this is no longer youtube super chat
letting everyone know the last few
minutes says
this has now become giannis's baby
shower so really start to cough it up
and
show your appreciation for the new baby
papa's making her way
into the [ __ ] chat very soon yeah
please yeah just come on guys this is uh
we need to get some toys for the baby
now webb slinger for 3.23 because
it's gonna become a thing in our super
chats now where people are just giving
us three dollars and 17 cents
more exactly 25 bucks he's asking new
york doesn't feel the same without
chrissy ha
thanks for the 25 bucks guys yeah thank
you
because for 25 bucks here i'll give you
one of these for 25 bucks
right yeah what's going on donnie so the
uh are you over the is he over the
girlfriend or what hold on
hold on ask it again
so the last time i was in uh last time i
was in los angeles
you had just broken up are you over it
or did you guys get back together for
corona
what's the deal wait hold on hold on
hold on hold on
hold on cuz yeah wait hold on one second
let me just get back in oh here we go
we're back
cuz you got no we're actually they're
back together she's in the next room
oh sorry yeah
so cuz if if you get me kicked out of
this [ __ ] place then i don't have
nowhere to go because i'm too scared to
be alone
because there is a person there who's
not happy that you're staying there
you know you know where donnie was right
before this he was in the other room
with the door closed
arguing with his girlfriend his
girlfriend was going why the [ __ ] he
here he's got a hotel room
why is he staying at our [ __ ] house
and donnie's going it's okay
it's fine he's just got you get scared
of the dark okay
the kid's got problems yeah let it go
yeah and she probably calls me gay slurs
in other languages
this is from ima again all caps
um chrissy d looks like he uses the
phrase
i don't believe in domestic violence but
yeah yeah it's another good one emma's
pretty funny
yeah no the truth is i don't hit women
they hit me yeah
that's actually the truth of the
situation uh what can you do
economy and unemployment are high i mean
unemployment's high but there's one
thing that's certain
is richie g is cashing checks
i mean because this kid just came in 150
large he says blanquito make no mistake
i see you're coming to kansas city in
march
i'll put you up in the nicest hotel
suite this dumb city has for the weekend
just to make up for how crappy the city
i've lived in
for six weeks is no strings attached
because i got you
wow here's the thing
you're gonna get him a hotel room and
that's much appreciated
but he's gonna leave that hotel room and
come sleep at your house
that's what it is so you might as well
just oh let me know what your apartment
number in because that's going to be
sleeping anyway if you don't give me the
number i'll find it anyway and you'll
wake up to a nice sniff on your big toe
because richie i mean what the [ __ ] does
richie do do what is he doing in kansas
city that he's making so much money that
means he's
in the house i don't know cuz ask
venetia she keeps lying on us and saying
she's in greece but i know she's richie
g's girlfriend
now here's the thing richie g is so not
ready to his type
oh why because he's white
that's it baby um we really appreciate
all the support truly we do
thank you guys so much for doing this
this is always fun to catch up with the
fans
and uh and yeah this is giannis baby
shower so this is how guys do it and
it's great did you hear that fart or no
before i did hear it yeah i did hear it
it's there what did you eat
so i gotta go yeah yeah you [ __ ] a
little bit huh
i [ __ ] a little bit so i gotta go take a
shower don unfortunately gonna have to
take another shower
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to patreon.com
where things get really wild